democrats aren't that excited about
having
joe biden as their candidate he also
needed someone
who could excite people as well and i
think kamala harris
could well be that candidate now let's
not forget she also stood for the
presidential nomination as well she has
experience
on the national stage and there was a
very pointed moment in one of those
uh debates last year where she had a
quite an intense and emotional clash
with joe biden over his uh
standing uh in his uh history
back in like several decades ago in his
career over the issue
of bussing and the segregation of
schools
she had a very pointed clash with him it
was quite uncomfortable
to watch her many wondered whether
perhaps that might be an issue for her
in terms of him picking her as his
candidate
some calling her too ambitious because
of course she ran for the
presidential nomination uh as well and
some saying that
perhaps joe biden wouldn't want a
candidate who had their eyes
on uh the election in 2024 well it seems
that joe biden
uh has been able to look past either of
those concerns
any of those issues and he does feel
that kamala harris
is the right person to have as his
running mate not just as his running
mate through the presidential
election but also potentially as his
vice president to serve with in the
white house
yes it's always awkward isn't it when
you've both run and you've criticized
the person who ends up being nominated
but
she's got the position hasn't she we now
know who the vice presidential running
mate is
for the democratic candidate joe biden